ladies and gentlemen please welcome to
the stage your host for the evening
Andrew Neil well good evening welcome to
Tuesday night at the London Palladium
if only my mother could see me now after
all these nights of the Sundays and you
know the snake still goes round I
checked that out but we're not going to
use that tonight though I first got to
know this place when Bruce Forsyth was
the compair so I think it's only fair I
should say nice to see you tessie you
nice now I thanks to Rathbones for being
our sponsors tonight The Spectator
magazine was founded in 1828 this is the
biggest event in the spectators long
history
there is clearly an appetite for
politics you are proof of that tonight
the motion before us the subject for
discussion is should Britain leave the
European Union we want you to be part of
this debate you can tweet with the
hashtag speck speck Brit that speck Brit
and the handle is at spectator events
all of the chairs of voting slips four
remain for leave or for undecided though
we hope most of you will not be
undecided but choose one way or the
other by the end of this debate tonight
we are any generous mood tonight so we
are giving away to a lucky winner a
year's free subscription to The
Spectator and free entry to the next
event happy you'll be wanting the shirt
off my back next and also we are giving
a special cut-price sub and a free
spectator mug lot of daily politics one
I'm afraid but definitely a spectator
when it makes the National lakhs of
lottery look absolutely parsimonious so
let's get on with it let us welcome our
debaters on tonight for the leap site
the leader of you Kip Nigel Faraj
for the remain site the former Deputy
Prime Minister Lib Dem MP Nick Clegg
for the lead site the conservative
member of the European Parliament Daniel
Hannan
for the remain site former Labour
leadership contender Labour MP Liz
Kendal
for the leave site Labour MP Kate Hoey
and for the remain side
Labour MP choco muna
so there we go leaves gentlemen these
are our debaters the format tonight is
that each will speak for five minutes
we're going to be quite tough on the
timing just to ensure fairness we will
then have some interplay between the
debaters and then we have some questions
chosen from the audience they know who
they are and I will call them and they
will go to the nearest microphone so
without further ado should Britain leave
the EU let me ask this Kendall to kick
off the debate for the remain side Liz
Kendall very much under it's a great
pleasure to be here tonight by the
strength of our common endeavor we
achieve more than we do alone so as to
create for each of us the means to
realize our true potential these words
written on Labour's membership card are
why I joined my party and I believe they
are as true for nation states as they
are for all of us here today the central
argument made by those who want us to
leave the EU is that brexit will give
Britain more control I couldn't disagree
more in a world that's more connected
than ever before real control the power
to shape our destiny rather than be left
to the mercy of events comes from
working with our neighbours and allies
to get the best for the British people I
think President Obama was absolutely
right last week when he said nations who
wield influence most effectively do it
through the collective action that
today's challenges demand being a member
of the EU gives Britain more influence
and power not less not just the power to
sell our goods to a market of 500
million people according to rules that
we helped to decide or to reach trade
agreements as part of a stronger bloc of
28 countries but the power to act
together when the rule of international
law is challenged on our own doorstep
like the sanctions regime imposed
following Russian aggression in Ukraine
and the power to tackle global
challenges like climate change using our
influence
to secure a better deal within the EU
and the --use influence to get a better
deal with the rest of the world now
cutting ourselves off from our neighbors
and allies in Europe and attempting to
go it alone would diminish Britain's
power not increase it and it would give
us less control to shape our future not
more but whilst I care passionately
about Britain's influence and role in
the world in the end this referendum
will come down to the central question
of our economy and whether we'll be more
prosperous in or out of the EU there is
not a single serious credible
independent organization that thinks
we'd be better off out the CBI says
brexit would cause a serious shock to
our economy the World Bank oacd
International Monetary Fund and ifs all
agree our economy would take a hit yet
some of those who back brexit like aaron
banks say even if there is an impact on
our economy it's a price worth paying
well I suppose at least he's being
honest but who will end up paying that
price not mr. banks not Dominic Cummings
who said there would definitely be
problems for some areas of our economy
or Boris Johnson who's admitted there
might be job losses no it will be those
who always suffer in an economic
downturn that end up paying the piper
price of brexit ordinary working people
the poor the vulnerable and the low paid
jobs lost incomes hid and businesses and
families left struggling to cope with
the consequences slower growth and lower
tax receipts reducing funding for the
public services we all rely on and for
what a mere mirage of greater control no
wonder our friends and allies are
speaking out like America Canada and
Australia that's what you do when you're
worried that our friends about to take a
decision that could harm them and you
Brittany's stronger in the EU and the EU
is stronger with Britain as one of its
members and who would cheer if we vote
for brexit people like vladimir putin
and marine lepen
nothing would please them more to see
Britain in the EU week and I don't want
us to play in their hands I know whose
side I am on the side of our true
friends and allies and the people I came
into politics to serve so whilst Frank
field might be worried about taking on
you Kip I am NOT but I am under no
illusions I think we're in the fight of
our lives the decision we take on June
the 23rd will define the future of our
country our economy the jobs and
investment we attract our safety and
security and our influence in the world
millions of people have yet to make up
their minds on the biggest question
facing our country in a generation
including labour supporters they deserve
Thank You entry they deserve a strong
and principled labour campaign making a
strong proud and patriotic case for our
membership of the EU and that's what I
for one I'm determined to do thank you
this candle and now to open the debate
for the leave side of the argument
please welcome you cave leader Nigel
Farage thank you good evening everybody
40 years ago we were inveigled into
voting to stay part of a common market
on the basis that it was all about trade
and nothing to do with politics and
those of you over the age of 58 who
voted for that common market undoubtedly
feel that you lied - and 40 years on
we're fighting a referendum where the
remain side or the Romanians as I think
they're now known but I love I'll come
on to immigration later the remain side
have clubbed together they've got
Goldman Sachs
they've got Siemens engineering they've
got the International Monetary Fund
they've got Obama they've got the
political class at least most of them in
Westminster telling us that if we do not
stay part of this political Union
dreadful things will happen to us
because we have this wonderful trade
deal being part of the European Union
they are doing it they are putting the
leave camp on the back foot and they're
doing it to try and put us off the main
arguments in this referendum the fact is
ladies and gentlemen we don't have a
good deal with the European Union for
access to the single market we pay a
membership fee we have the free movement
of people we have a massive regulatory
burden and we're prohibited and stopped
from making our own trade friendships
with the rest of the world do not
believe them when they tell you tonight
that the single market is good for
Britain that we need to be part of this
club to access the single market every
country in the world access is the
single market and even in the worst case
scenario that Britain does not have a
successful renegotiation and simply has
to rely on WTO rules even in that
scenario
the cost of tariffs would be less than
our net contribution so don't listen to
politicians who've never bought and sold
a cargo or a product or a good in their
lives business is dumb because consumers
choose to buy products at the right
price
now the real debate in this referendum
is we have an opportunity a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to vote
to take back the independence
self-governance and control of this
country's laws of this country's courts
and crucially of this country's borders
and I'm urging you tonight to support
this motion I believe in democracy I
believe that if you get a government
that makes bad laws you should after
five years be able to turf them out and
replace them with somebody else who
undoes the damage that they've done when
a European law is made there is nothing
that you the voters the House of Commons
or the British government can do to
reverse a single piece of European
legislation there is no direct
democratic accountability within this
European system and frankly I believe
that those that went before us and
sacrifice so much in two world wars did
so so that we could be a free
independent sovereign nation that
governs itself and part of that is we've
lost control of our borders net
migration into Britain is now running at
10 times the post-war average and that's
if you believe the official figures
which frankly I don't we have to build a
new house in this country every seven
minutes just to cope with current levels
of immigration we are short tens of
thousands of primary school places for
this September and the National Health
Service is under literally intolerable
pressure what we need to do is take back
control of our borders to say that our
passport should not be available to five
hundred and eight million people and
let's put in place
brexit a sensible proper normal
immigration policy along the style that
the Australians do let's have people
with skills and trades to bring let's
have people who haven't got criminal
records which is novel for the AHS ISM
and let's one minute and let's have
people who will add and contribute to
the economy but let's have them in
sensible numbers and in this age of
terrorism when you remember that two of
the people that caused the massacre in
Paris had come into Europe posing as
migrants through the Greek islands will
be safer and better and more secure
taking back control of our borders
putting in place a proper immigration
system getting back the sovereignty of
our Parliament and our courts re
embracing the parts of the world that we
turned our backs on like the
Commonwealth and elsewhere whilst at the
same time being friends and neighbors
with all of those in Europe this
opportunity must not be passed up let's
take back control of our lives let's
believe it ourselves let's believe in
Britain let's believe in a better
stronger future for our nation thank
Nigel Faraj please welcome now our
second speaker for the remain site of
the debate Liberal Democratic MP former
Deputy Prime Minister Nick Clegg
you're going to hear or be subject to
lots of claims and counterclaims facts
and counter facts insults and counter
insults during the next hour or so this
evening but I would just invite you to
hold three big thoughts in in mind as
you listen to the sort of tooing and
froing
on this stage and the first one is this
that of course this referendum is a lot
about what we all collectively and
individually think about the European
Union whether we think the Europeans a
good thing or a bad thing but the more
that this debate has continued over the
last several weeks the more I have the
feeling that in many ways this debate is
about who we are who what Great Britain
is what are we going to be as a country
now and in the future are we going to be
an open country or a closed country are
we going to be a country that is engaged
with our near neighbors in the European
Union or increasingly dis engaged are we
going to be a United Kingdom at all
Nicola Sturgeon could not have been
clearer just a few days ago that if we
were to vote as a country to leave the
European Union that would then trigger a
second referendum in Scotland so it's
not just one union our place in the
European Union which is at stake it is
also our own union the union of the
United Kingdom which is at stake as well
so first big thought this isn't just
about what you think about the EU and
Brussels it's also what we think about
ourselves now and in the future the
second sort of simple thought is the the
point that both Nigel is if from from
different points of view I need us to
agree with Liz well Nigel have already
mentioned now which is this word control
how do you in a Footloose fancy free
globalised world in which criminals
trade flows financial transactions
pollution don't none of those things
recognize borders how do you how do you
reassert control in that much more
complex fluid world that we now inhabit
and my I mean Nigel
I'll say put it with great vigor he's
deeply misguided but he said it my long
LS with great vigor is we should put on
the drawbridge we should return to a
sort of 19th century vision of Britain
the age of sort of gumbo gumbo diplomacy
on the rest of it I don't think that is
available to us anymore I think the only
way that we can control or maximize
control over our own destiny over our
own economic fortunes over safety on our
streets over the quality of the air we
breathe is by working hand in glove with
our nearest neighbors in the European
Union we are safer we are stronger in
many respects we're bigger together than
we are apart and the third and final
thing is this it's about the the nature
of this vote that we're going to have on
the 23rd of June because it's quite
quite different to any other kind of
vote that we customarily a cast in our
in our lives it's not like a general
election over important they seem which
sort of bind the hands of the the next
Parliament for the next five years or or
set expectations about what a government
will do this is a once-in-a-generation
vote if we decide to close the door in
the face of Europe lock the lock the
door throw the key away we're not only
in my view denying opportunities for us
now but most importantly we're doing so
far we're closing off opportunities for
future generations for my kids for your
kids for all of our our grandchildren
and in many respects that makes this
vote so different to anything we've had
to do before because we mustn't just
think about ourselves we must also think
about the duty we have to future
generations because they are the ones
they are the ones who will have to live
with the consequences of the decision
taken by this generation more than
anyone anyone sitting in this theater
this evening that is my strongly held
belief but to do the right thing for my
own children yet alone for the for the
country that I love I believe however
floor the European Union and of course
it is that our children our the future
generations of this country will be
safer will be better off will be
stronger by remaining in
the European Union thank you very much
nick clegg please welcome now the second
speaker tonight speaking for leave
please welcome the Labour MP Kate Hoey
Tony been called the EU a derogation of
our historic democratic right to select
and remove our governments he was right
then he's right now the Labour Party as
you know was a whole when I joined it
was very sceptical towards the Common
Market and there's still some in
Parliament today who were elected
including Jeremy Corbyn on a manifesto
of leaving the EU I'm very proud to be
following in the footsteps of great
labour figures whose Democratic
credentials can never be doubted Hugh
gates go pita Shore and people like
Barbara castle the labour movements
roots were to represent the interests of
the workers against big business the
roots have shrunk then if they have and
they are then so has a true meaning of
left-wing politics and we need to
refresh them preserving the right to
elect our governments who make the laws
that we have to carry out is the basic
minimum of people's rights it's the
basis of all other rights and without it
rights can easily be taken away and I
don't believe you can trust people in
power if they cannot be removed by
elections now no one can deny that the
--use government the Commission is
unelected and cannot be removed by any
of us or elections and that fact alone
is reason to me enough to reject the EU
regardless of all the other
considerations that you will hear
tonight if we were looking now into
joining the EU as it is if we were
looking now to join it as it is the vast
majority of people would be absolutely
horrified at its anti-democratic status
and I've been in the labour party for
many years and occasionally I'd be known
to Driss agree with my party's majority
view but I'm in the labour party because
I care about our public services and the
service that they provide the most
vulnerable and the EU is going down a
neoliberal path to open up those very
services to global tax dodging
multinational corporations now many
people in my party think vaguely
of the EU is some kind of social
democracy it isn't a socialist it isn't
democratic it is exactly the opposite it
is corporis and anti-democratic and the
EU is finding principles the four
principles of capitalism the four
principles four pillars of the EU free
movement of goods services labor and
capital and those are the principles of
a free market they are not the
principles of a political system and the
--use purpose is to rule in the
interests of the smooth running of a
corporatist economy without regard to
the encumbrance of an electorate is this
something that liberal voters or anyone
else can support to as a Barroso
president of the unelected Commission
made it very clear in 2014 the EU is an
antidote to democratic government you
know how can he actually even try to
pretend that he trusts the sense of
decisions of the people another reason
many liberal voices support the EU is
that they believe it somehow favors
workers interests the so called social
chapter was offered to the unions in
exchange for acceptance of the
anti-democratic nature of the EU and
they fell for it it offered regulations
about working hours and holidays which
could easily have been achieved by
democratic means and serve most to
create an acceptable image for the
capitalist EU this is perhaps the
cleverest fraud of all it does nothing
of the kind it seeks to make out of the
four hundred and fifty million people a
vast sea of migrant labour the biggest
pull of migrant labour since the 1930s
America in America now migrant laborers
are forced to work for a minimum wage
and can be excluded from Union rates by
EU law a good example being the Laval
case in Sweden the EU has even
prosecuted unions for trying to get
union writs for migrant workers why
because they want to make cheap labor
available right across Europe despite
the hardship in an upheaval it creates
at least when we oppose and I oppose the
policies of this Conservative government
we can actually look to voting them out
and reverse their policies we can't do
that with an unelected EU Commission and
it's similarly on all the
environmentalists issues the EU some
people will say is good for regulations
of emissions poisonous substance
is again it's a exactly the wrong prayer
impression and this has been made very
clear by the TTIP trade agreement
negotiated in secret by the EU not only
does it give the go-ahead to US
corporations to sue governments for loss
of profits threaten the enforced
privatisation of the NHS and to impose
GM foods despite British bands and to
make it impossible to regulate against
harmful chemicals it actually creates
the legal conditions the undermine the
very abilities of elected government to
make laws in the interests of the people
against the immense power of the
multinationals there could be no clear
indication of what the EU really is an
attempt to replace the Democratic part
of the permanent administration and
interests of very big business
everything else is a smokescreen when I
can't see understand how anyone on the
Left who opposes TTIP would want to
remain in the EU and that's very clear
why Obama was threatening us people
people who know people who know how
dangerous the EU talk of reforming it
from within they know that that can
never be reformed the best way to secure
our freedom and democracy in Europe is
for the United Kingdom to leave the you
to leave the EU and finally for people
who keep saying what does leave look
like well I tell you what it looks like
it looks like all the other 169
countries in the world just meant most
of them with true democratic
accountability free trade border
controls and so on
so the question is what what let us be
clear there is no certainty about
remaining in the EU the price of true
freedom is uncertainty the price of
certainty is a form of servitude and we
need to set our country free from that
future servitude
you
please Hui
please welcome now our third speaker for
remain tonight
Labour MP juco muna thank you very much
and rien thank you to all of you for
coming what a fantastic audience look
the EU isn't perfect of course it needs
reform but I don't think any of the
three of us are arguing that and
actually that isn't the question that
we've been asked on the 23rd of June we
are being are simply do we believe we
are safer stronger and better off in
than out and I'm very clear they were
better off in now look Nigel and Kate
have told you that we should get out
because we've got no control over our
own affairs now just think about that
for the moment
in fact Kate Liz and I have spent the
last six years campaigning as Labour MPs
against things like the bedroom tax the
top-down reorganisation of the NHS
taking tax credits away from the working
poor you name it there's a long list now
whatever you think about those things
they have all been implemented by a Tory
led domestic government the EU had
absolutely nothing to do with those
things or many of the things we see
being talked about on our news every
single day now on the issues where we do
work with our EU partners it's simply
not true that we get walked over
trampled over whenever we want to get
things die
done why do we have people talking down
Britain's influence in the EU and abroad
in that way particularly when if you
look at the EU council 9 out of 10 times
we're on the majority side so I talk
down our country in this way and look if
it's controlled that you care about you
don't increase your control by giving up
your power and your influence Britain
has always pooled sovereignty and worked
with other nations there's been a member
of the UN mean that we don't have
control over our destiny of course not
just being a member of NATO a leading
member of NATO mean that we don't
control our own affairs of course not
and look if you took the leave
campaigners argument to its logical
for conclusion let me sovereign nation
there will probably be no North Korea
because they don't really work with
anybody now apparently the three of us
make this argument as nigel hinted at
because we're part of this kind of
global elite which takes in lem
mccroskey the head of unite working with
those well-known socialists at the CBI
and of course not forgetting Christine
Lagarde at the IMF all of this being
orchestrated by President Obama at the
behest of Len McCluskey's new best mate
David Cameron what complete and utter
Tosh but look most of all I'm concerned
as Nick said for what we bequeath to the
future generations by some margin on
this stage I think I'm the youngest
personally I was still at university
when Nigel Nick and Dan joined the
European Parliament but the point is the
idea of us working and networking with
others in this interconnected world it
makes so much sense for the young and
future generations because that is what
they're used to that's what they've
grown up in we're not war with these
guys anymore Nigel this isn't the 1940s
or the 1950s this is 2016 and they are
going to have to live with this decision
for far longer than any of us on this
stage now we live in a big and complex
world and I think you can either adopt a
small Britain a small vision of Britain
in this very different world where we
sit on the sidelines we're not at the
top table we fail to live up to our
great history of punching above our
weight in the world or all we can
bequeath to the next generation a big
vision of our country proud of our
history proud of what we've achieved in
the past but ambitious and
self-confident for what Britain can
achieve in the future not only for
people at home but in terms of building
that fairer more secure better world
abroad that we want to see so I say
let's go big let's make Britain even
greater than it is already and reject
the small vision for our country that
you see offered by the people who want
us to pull out of the European Union
let's stand tall that is what this you
referendum is about
chuckle Munna and our third speaker
tonight for the leave site of the
proposition please welcome conservative
member of the European Parliament Daniel
Hannan
ladies and gentlemen I'm inviting you to
make me redundant and indeed in the
bargain make my jewel redundant and I
wouldn't be doing that if I were not
confident there will be plenty of
openings for newly unemployed MEP s in
the boom that will come to this country
after we've left the European Union and
I'll tell you why I am so confident
about that prediction if I put it in one
word it would be obsolete we just heard
from chucker that these are that not the
1950s he said it as though he was
imparting an original insight absolutely
these are not the 1950s and that's why
we have outgrown a top-down dirige East
construct a hangover of an age when
freight costs were high and
refrigeration was expensive and regional
trade bloc's looked like the future but
my friends that world has been made
completely redundant by technological
advance this is an age of the internet
of cheap flights of Skype is as easy to
do business with a company in New
Zealand as with a company in France in
fact easier because the Kiwi company
will be english-speaking and common law
never before has geographical proximity
been as irrelevant as now so why why do
we tie ourselves to though one part of
the world that is not experiencing
significant economic growth over the
last 10 years China's economy has
doubled in size India's economy has
doubled in size
Ethiopia's economy has doubled in size
but the eurozone incredibly was the same
size at the end of last year as it had
been in 2006 every continent on this
planet has grown over the past decade
except Antarctica and Europe now we are
a trading people we're a maritime people
our people connected by language and law
by habit and history by Commerce and
migration to every continent at
archipelago we don't sit on great
natural resources here we have to make
our way in the world by what we buy and
sell that means we have to be
customers are and as long as we're in
the European Union we cannot sign
independent trade agreements with non EU
countries the EU deal with Australia is
being held up because some Italian
tomato growers are currently challenging
it the EU deal with Canada is being held
up because of an unrelated dispute about
Romanian visas how have we put ourselves
in a position where we can't do those
deals liz cited a few of the big
international quangos and the davos men
who tell us that it's in our interest to
stay she said there's nothing in it for
the little guy let me cite a couple of
people who are leaders of the remain
campaign Paddy Ashdown says if we leave
it'll mean cheaper food and Lourdes Rose
says if we leave it'll mean higher wages
now I would have thought that if liz is
really interested in the interests of
the working people that she says she's
speaking for she would give more weight
to those opinions than to those of the
tax-free michelin-starred international
quango crowd who she sees as the
arbiters of our national interest why
are we paying to belong to the world's
only stagnant customs union paying 19
billion pounds gross eleven billion
pounds net every year right to put this
in context in the last we just heard
about the cuts and you know the the
Labour MPs were standing against all
these coalition reductions in the last
Parliament the 2010 to 2015 Parliament
according to the IFS the entire
austerity program saved 36 billion
pounds over that lifetime of the same
Parliament are gross contribution to the
EU was 85 billion pounds our net
contribution was 42 billion pounds so
even if you insist on taking the net
figure that one clean excision would
have wiped out the whole of the
austerity program and still given us
enough left over to take a penny of
income tax it's not just the financial
price it's the democratic price we
fought a civil war in this country to
establish the principle that laws should
not be passed nor taxes raised except by
our own elected representatives and now
supreme legislative and executive power
is held not just by people that you
didn't vote for the people that I had I
should let people who generally oh there
having just lost elections like Peter
Mandelson and Neil Kinnock and now acts
like there's only one they've been
expressly rejected by their electorate
that they are invited to come and
legislate for us anyway now look if the
EU were about cooperating if it were
like meso and all the things that
chuckles say no one would have a problem
with it right you'd have to be insane to
be against the idea of working with
neighboring countries can we take it as
read that all of us on this platform all
of you in this room are in favor of
cooperating with our immediate neighbors
and allies the problem is that it
presumes to legislate for us that it
wants to take on the attributes and
trappings of statehood no one is talking
I mean Nick trotted out all the cliches
of our more bridges and throwing away
keys no one is talking about isolation I
know where else in the world two
countries apologize for wanting to live
under their own laws you know New
Zealand is not about to join Australia
and we don't go around saying all these
dreadful or straw low sceptics when are
they going to understand that they're a
small offshore island clinging to
outdated notions of sovereignty right
Japan is not applying to join China as
far as I'm aware and people don't say oh
these bigoted sino skeptics when are
they gonna get it through their heads
that they've lost their empire it is
unnatural healthy thing for a democracy
to live under its own laws while trading
and cooperating with every other country
in the
we are the fifth largest economy on the
planet where the fourth military power
were one of five members of the UN
Security Council how much bigger do we
have to be before we have the confidence
to raise our eyes to more distant
horizons and rediscover that global
vocation which we once took for granted
Daniel Hannan now in a minute I'm going
to go and get some questions from the
audience but before I do just let me ask
a couple of my own a Nigel Farage Nick
Clegg says you just want to pull up the
drawbridge why no Nick I don't want to
pull up the drawbridge
I want to control who's coming over the
drawbridge that's what we get by being
an independent nation nick clegg what's
the question he's where he says he
hasn't got a drawbridge but if he did he
would control people who work across it
we want control migration Andrew we want
controlled migration into a gunking I
get I get that I open door why why in
that case if being in the European Union
is the genesis of all the anxiety by
immigration why is it then per head of
population Australia and Canada have
twice higher rates of immigration than
we do then on members of the European
Union the United States has a net
increase of a million people every year
they're not a member of the European
Union there is this absurd assumption in
what Nigel Faraj another say that those
desperate desperate refugees fleeing
from conflict and destitution in Syria
will somehow stop trying to come here
the moment we're not members of the
European Union they are fleeing
persecution and violence they just want
to be safe we've got to have a slightly
more adult conversation with immigration
immigrant people moving large distances
in large numbers happens in every
continent around the world it is not
something created in Brussels by the
European Union and it is profoundly
misleading to claim otherwise
how'd your Faraj peak reply yeah I'm
sorry Nick but but the British passport
is now held by five hundred and eight
million people any of whom can come to
this country other would say the reason
that Australia and Canada pro-rata can
take more migrants that weekend is
they've got rather more space and rather
more room than we have
but net migration from outside the EU is
higher than net migration from inside
the ER and that's bad British government
and I agree with that and I'm not saying
that for all of our faults have come
from the EU there's a lot lead sorting
out at Westminster too but the fact is
we have an open door and we're members
of a European Union whose stated aim is
to bring in new countries like Bosnia
like Albania and crucially mrs. Merkel
and she's the real boss these days and
mrs. Merkel wants Turkey to be a member
by 2025 so we're part of a union that is
letting in poorer and poorer countries
who ultimately will have unrivaled free
access to our nation and I think the
point has come frankly where enough is
enough sugar Munna what do you say to
Dan Hannah's point that by being the EU
we've shackled ourselves to what is now
the slowest growing part of the OECD of
the advanced economies well they're our
biggest customer
we export 44 percent of our goods over
to the EU and that helps create jobs
here I should just say I mean that on
this point of immigration I'm a son of
an immigrant and I know there you come
back to come back to that I know I will
but just on the economic point which is
what my question was about
about 12 years ago we exported 55% of
goods and services to the EU it's now 44
percent and falling that may be because
demand has fallen because it is so slow
growing so my question was why would we
shackle ourselves to an economy that has
been stagnant now for almost a decade
but I don't believe that we are shackled
because of course it's not just the
trade that we have with our biggest
customer in the single market we also
have access to the various different
trade agreements the European Union has
with non EU countries and I don't buy
this proposition that either we go after
our EU custom or we pursue opportunities
say in the Commonwealth my family or in
the Commonwealth we actually need to do
both if you're running a business you
don't just ignore your existing client
base to go after new ones you seek to do
both at the same time so it's not an
either/or scenario it's not about means
shackle to the European Union and/or
pursuing other opportunities elsewhere
we need to do both and that's
fundamental when we have such a big
trade deficit except that the EU has
done free trade deals with other
countries their amount to seven trillion
dollars of global GDP
Switzerland's done free trade deals with
other countries there are monster 40
trillion dollars of global GDP are we
not missing out no I don't think we are
and if
iDate I don't believe I don't believe we
serve in verses 14 I don't believe we
are missing out well that would be to
dismiss let me just give you an example
I was speaking to the head of Fujitsu in
the UK today they employ 20,000 people
in this country and they've had three
they've invested 3.9 billion pounds in
the UK so more than Nissan and Toyota
put together now when they made that
investment decision three to four years
ago they could either come and make that
investment at Fujitsu here in the UK or
they could go to Italy Germany or France
and in the end they chose to make that
investment here in part and very
important part because we are part of
the European Union so you can laugh at
the figures but that is a reality in
terms of jobs and I've just given you
one company there and I could give you
many others because in the end is about
people's livelihoods this let me put
that pointer down Hannon it isn't just
our trade with the EU which is still
substantial at 44% there are many
companies in this country because we are
a member of the European Union and I'll
give you two examples ah they're both
Swiss Credit Suisse in UBS are in this
country because financial services is
not part of their agreement with the EU
Switzerland's agreement so the big Swiss
banks have come to London because
they're inside the EU what by the fact
that they're here you demonstrate that
you don't have to be a member of the EU
to be trading with the EU no but they're
here because we're in the EU if you
narrowly look at financial services the
EU the other 27 members of the EU take
33 percent of our financial services
export the US when nobody pretends that
there's any kind of single market on its
own takes 31 percent right and this is
because we are a global trading country
and I know which of those I think is
going to be the longer the better long
term prospect Chuck I said something
which was true and important he said it
shouldn't be an either/or choice
we shouldn't have to choose between
trading in the EU and trading with us
the world I absolutely agree and that's
why I'm urging people to vote no there
is a free-trade area there is a tariff
free zone
that stretches across the continent from
non-eu Iceland to non-eu Turkey there
are no tariffs in that area
the only geographical European state
that is not part of that free trade area
is Belarus so no one is seriously
suggesting in Brussels that if Britain
left the political structures of the EU
we'd be excluding ourselves from that
free trade area but we would be gaining
the capacity to sign bilateral deals as
Switzerland does with China with India
with the bits of the world that are in
fact growing right I'm going to go to
the audience and to Henri Majel if you
could get to a microphone but I promised
chuka I would come back on the
immigration point you wanted to make
well actually I was just going to come
back on the point that Daniels just made
good on the immigration point our
country has many problems we don't have
enough homes we need to invest in our
public services which are being drained
at the moment but I think we do a great
disservice to the immigration debate if
we simply seek to blame all of this on
immigration its domestic governments of
different political persuasions who in
the end haven't done what needs to be
done and the other side of the coin is
of course we've got two million Brits
who are benefiting from me free movement
and live in the EU we've got EU citizens
who've set up businesses here which
employ 1.5 million people and our NHS
which is of course the big story today
that over a hundred thousand you
nationals helping our NHS function so
let's have a more mature and balanced
debate about creation in this country
totally I just go to the audience as a
service to us Thank You Tucker moona
Henry Maddow good evening I have
recently graduated and I'm now training
to be a lawyer I have 36 thousand pounds
of student debt why should I vote to
leave the European Union when to do so
would surely increase economic
uncertainty Kate Hoey well as I said I
don't actually think that leaving the EU
is creating anything other than a
certainty that we will be able to make
our own decisions and and do work in in
the way that we want to as an elected
government on his elected opposition in
terms of student fees we
you know that is not directly affected
by I accept by the EU no but what he's
asking is he's got a lot of debt round
his neck right now
yeah he's training to be a lawyer so
actually he'll probably get rid of that
debt quite quickly um but anyway I have
to pay the fees uh what he wants is what
give him that he's got that debt round
his neck why would he vote for economic
uncertainty because there has to be
surely if we leave a degree of
uncertainty um there's a degree of
uncertainty in the probably the initial
phases and there's no divider the CBI
report came out and said that initially
there would be some uncertainty and
there would be some some perhaps
slowness but ultimately we would be
better off out and I do think that you
know your individual case is is you know
is is upsetting for you but I see
absolutely no reason why we well of
course it's upsetting for everybody
who's got debt and I'm one of those
people who was educated because there
was absolutely no fee to pay and I voted
against the increase of and putting any
any fees at all on student grants
because I think actually what we did as
a Labour government was trying to send
far too many people to university and
ignore all those people who could anyway
that's getting away from certainly yes
I'm gonna stop you know it's a scandal
no no you got away from the point you
don't get a second chance Liz can you
inspire to say there's also uncertainty
if we stay and isn't I mean the eurozone
is still stagnant uh there are serious
political problems in many of these
eurozone countries not just you cannot
economic problems as a major migrant
crisis unfolding for the second year
there's uncertainty whether we leave or
stay of course there is the world is an
uncertain place but in answer to the
question you shouldn't vote for greater
risk in the economy I mean one of the
problems I think that the leave campaign
has is they've still not been able to
describe the kind of deal that they want
to negotiate you know are we going to be
Norway we're going to be Switzerland are
we going to be Canada or the latest
Albania
and we don't know what the impact will
be on prices on tariffs on growth on
investment on job creation and as I said
most serious credible independent
organizations and I would say Kate you
know trade unions representing 4 million
working people believe that our economy
will be hit will be worse off and it'll
be people on low pay and with debts
who'll suffer the most that's always
what happens in an economic downturn so
don't go charity your your organization
actually say that he that wages would
rise still rose who who's been heading
your campaign that we've not heard much
of them lately
if he's watching this thing I can't like
into a profit he said that if we left
wages would probably rise because they'd
be less cheap labor and you didn't think
that was a good thing well you know on
the counter side the counterbalance to
that as I said is the CPI the IMF the
World Bank is video campus well he knows
no doubt
I have his opinions on that but I think
most people think that there will be a
risk and I just don't think it's well is
it nearly all those people wrong and
some of them on this on this platform as
well said that we would be so much worse
off if we didn't join the euro including
Nick like that well I've never said that
in my life so I'm not gonna lie you've
never been in favor of the Euro this
candle no Nick Clegg you wrote in
Prospect magazine in 2002 that if we
remain outside the Europe we will simply
continue to subside into a position of
relative poverty and inefficiency
compared to our more prosperous European
neighbors
would you um would you like to delete
that now yes yes I would can I just and
I gotta talk to Henry it's too late I've
got the cash you like the my topic
hey Henry where are you yeah I don't
think I'm probably the best placed
person to talk about tuition fees and so
I won't i won't i won't address that
night just to point out though that if
you don't earn the obviou you won't have
to pay but anyway anyway and the point i
was i talk to you about Henry's because
you said you know about your future your
qualifying to be a lawyer right okay
you might I assume you might want to
enjoy the opportunity to travel and work
around the European Union as a lawyer as
a newly qualified lawyer now here's the
thing under the single mark and this is
what the outlet always deliberately
obscure they talk about old-fashioned
trade is if it's all about tariffs those
are the taxes you put on physical goods
actually the modern trade is all about
the rules including for instance
qualifications for lawyers that impede
the free movement of people and the
establishment of businesses Assad if
your law firm wants to practice law in
Denver or Spain or Finland or wherever
across the European Union under the
present single market arrangement by the
way an invention of a British then
European Commissioner Lord Lord Cofield
established by Margaret Thatcher's
government in the single European Act
the biggest pooling of sovereignty dan
by any British government in the
post-war period what they did in my view
right clear intelligently was recognized
that modern trade is not this
old-fashioned stuff about tariffs it's
about the laws the the technical
standards the could the the
qualification case under the non tariff
non-tariff barriers I need to get
another question no no it's very
important this if he if we pull out of
the European Union Henry will not be
able to work as a lawyer elsewhere in
the European Union and if we then as a
country decide to conform to those rules
if we conform to those rules will do
what Norway and Iceland got does will
not be at the table where those rules
are made and will still be subject right
in other words a guy knows you offic
loss of sovereignty okay how many of
either no no don't
like the early a lot of questions to go
through and it this event is for the
people out there as much as for the
people up here
Edie Potter next question from you and
thank you the debate has been heavy on
the economics of leave and remain isn't
a more important reason to remain in the
EU its role as a guarantor of peace in
Western Europe and it's and as a
promoter of democracy in Southern and
Eastern Europe a guarantor of peace in
Western Europe a promoter of democracy
in southern Eastern Europe dan Hanna ask
yourself one question ed does it make
more sense to see the EU as a cause of
post-war peace in Europe or doesn't it
make more sense to see it as a
consequence of a peace that was based on
the defeat of fascism the spread of
democracy and to some extent the NATO
alliance it's necessarily difficult to
answer counterfactuals but look at the
effect that excessive integration is
having on relations among European
countries now the euro and the Schengen
zone are the two great pillars of
integration the current president of the
Commission with that peculiar
imperviousness to events that defines
his caste still says that they are the
two greatest successes of the European
now would you the European Union or
would you say that they are making
countries get on better or less well
look at how German newspapers write
about Greece
look at how Greek newspapers write about
Germany are they soothing or stoking
national antagonism here's the the
question that I would put to people who
think that the EU is the guarantor of
peace in Europe look at the other parts
of the world where democracy and trade
have spread and where without needing
supranational structures they've solved
the problem of interstate war there's
been no major conflict in North America
since 1865 that end not in European
Union
setting aside tiny border skirmishes has
been no interstate war in South America
since 1941 they're not in the European
Union Switzerland has not known internal
conflict since 1848
or interstate war since 1815 and it's
not in the European Union so the idea
that we owe our peace any more than we
owe our democracy or our prosperity to
jean-claude Juncker I think is an insult
to the people who have actually policed
the peace on this continent and those
are the people in British and American
uniforms Sugarman oh well Leslie you
made a contribution to peace and
democracy it has but let me just say
something about North America the reason
hasn't been a war in North America I
presume is because they've pulled
sovereignty and the different united
states work together in one united union
of states but look this point on the e
use contribution to peace on the
continent in our region I think people
often forget that in the 70 odd years
before the EU came into being France and
Germany went to war no less than three
times and a lot of blood was spilled as
a result now I wouldn't say that since
then and of course it would be
absolutely unthinkable for that to
happen now I wouldn't say that since
then the only reason that we've had
peace in Europe has been because of the
European Union NATO of course has played
a role but my gosh it has made a
tremendous contribution to ensuring that
we don't have that kind of situation
happening again because we work together
to solve common challenges I think one
of the biggest things that worries me
about politics in advanced economies is
that the globalization has brought a
huge amount of uncertainty people feel
incredibly insecure there are lots of
opportunities but it's also quite
frightening the change to now of course
there's a natural human instinct in that
sense and in that context to look at who
do we blame for all this uncertainty in
insecurity and juxtaposed against there
is a desire to actually work with others
to tackle the big challenges that we
face now I'd much rather we adopt the
latter position than the kind of former
if I call it Donald Trump view of the
world where we just seek to blame
everybody for our problems instead of
working together with others who share
our values
to meet these big common challenges that
we have all right it's not a fundamental
point about democracy quickly Nigel
Farage and when to go after the walls
next we was trying to credit the
European Union with spreading democracy
well the European is very good at
encouraging the growth of democracy in
countries until they join the European
Union and then it's very good at trying
to take away democracy from them I
explained to you earlier that the people
who have the sole right to propose
legislation and the reform of
legislation within the European system
are the unelected European Commission
when they propose the law and it's gone
through the Machine there is nothing the
voters or national parliaments or
national governments can do to change a
single piece of legislation it is not
just undemocratic the system is
fundamentally anti-democratic and it's
got so bad but during the eurozone
crisis we even saw the premier of Greece
and the Premier of Italy removed
virtually by a coup d'etat
from the European Commission and
replaced with former Goldman Sachs
employees the European Union is the
death of democracy for that reason if
nothing else we should leave it and get
back to being a self-governing Democrat
alright thank you
next question from Alain Gibbs thank you
many of the arguments over the past
months and we've heard some more of them
tonight that have come from the remain
camp have been framed in negative terms
can we now hear the single most positive
reason the remain camp believes exists
for us staying within the Union single
most positive reason for staying in this
candle because if we complete the single
market to cover services I think we're
going to see you know more opportunities
for jobs and growth in future I think
you know building a stronger economy is
still the biggest challenge we've got in
this country and a completed single
market I think will be great for Britain
secondly climate change I thought
actually
you just wanted once a brother single
most positive reason I know can I say
just a sort of slightly disagree with
the questioner I believe that making a
positive case for tackling climate
change is a really important part of our
membership from of the EU and I just on
the point of hold on on the point on
jobs which you gave is the single most
positive reason why are you so confident
of that when the continent of Europe is
awash with massed
youth unemployment I would actually end
you like to see many countries in Europe
do far more to boost jobs and growth and
tackle unemployment that's why I believe
in reform within the EU but without
doubt if we complete that single market
in services many organizations believe
will see more opportunities for our
companies and I want to see that happen
Nick Clegg the single most positive
reason safety numbers I think ok I
really I mean by the Costales jobs point
if the European Union was the reason for
unemployment why on earth we have some
of the lowest unemployment in Europe
after 40 years of membership it's a
ludicrous assertion to somehow say that
and they actually have you fainted on
hold on hold on so the fact that we have
much lower unemployment in this country
compared to other European Union
economies shows that we can have access
to what is the world's largest
borderless marketplace and yet still
govern our own rules as far as labor
laws are concerned we have a much more
flexible labor market we have the best
of both worlds it would be madness for
the opportunities which we should be
securing and offering to future
generations to throw that all away for
what for a future is it Norway's its
wits alone is an albanian is it Canada
you can't even tell us what future you
want to provide for us all right and if
you can't tell us what happens if we
stay in I staying in is not the same
exact time and so I come back being on
an away event I go hold on the Clegg on
come back to you then a really critical
point to understand the European Union
is changing and it's changing rapidly
because it's dealing with these twin
crises the Schengen crisis and the euro
crisis and it's responding to both of
them in the way that it responsibly
everything else with more integration
now Britain has other options because we
kept the pound because we didn't join
Schengen we have an alternative we can
reorient away from a declining innovated
eurozone towards the rest of the world
but you need to understand that there
are risks both ways you don't know what
unemployment is gonna be if we say you
don't know how many more bailouts we're
gonna be dragged into how much more
integration how much migration either
way there are risks but we must be safer
if we can mitigate those risks ourselves
by taking back control of our own
democracy Nick Clegg of course of course
there's no one's gonna be foolish enough
I hope on either side of the debate to
pretend they can tell the future of
course they like to Kingdom will develop
in ways we can't fully predict the
European Union quite right has some
problems which it needs to deal with
which will develop in ways we can't
fully predict but two things firstly as
you have just pointed out yourself we
can create a status for ourselves in the
European Union which secures the best of
both worlds we have access to the single
market we're not part of the eurozone
we're not part of Schengen we have a
secure a whole range of other options or
opt outs which means that the European
is not the straightjacket on our
identity which you seek to imply it's a
much much more flexible arrangement than
that the one thing I can tell you about
the future is this I cannot think of a
single major challenge which our kids
and our grandkids will face which
doesn't require a supranational
international recite you cannot deal
with climate change you cannot deal with
passports crime you cannot deal with
terrorism you cannot deal with
globalization you cannot deal with
international trade you cannot deal with
the unsettling effects of financial
markets without acting together
everybody's not European we clearly see
this upside right here Hennessy alright
let's go to our next question Stuart
wheeler given the duties for non EU
countries average only about 1.3 percent
why is axe
to the single market show important
joker Mona sorry could you
oh I repeated sorry big event given that
the average duties using WTO figures for
non EU countries the average only about
1.3 percent that's on goods not not on
services building goods why is given
that these tariffs are so low under WTO
rules why is access to the single market
so important well you made the point in
a way and was the question from what was
the name of the questioner Stuart
wheeler ah actually since I can't seem
I'm not sure if it's the same Stuart
wheeler you at you from the voice I
think it is anyway but regardless of the
voice what's the answer I can see him it
is the point is though under those WTO
rules we're not talking about services
and services make up 80 percent of the
UK economy and can I just say something
on this particular point because we have
been asked to believe that we are a
great country as I said in my opening
remarks with a fifth largest economy in
the world yes and it is asserted that we
will be able to get a trade deal with
the EU if we were to leave pretty much
on the same terms as we have at the
moment now just think about that for a
moment that is asking you to believe
that our European partners would give us
a deal that they don't even have
themselves so they would give us access
to the single market without us having
to be paying a fee to be part of it
presumably there's a presumption also
that we'll be able to have some say in
the rules of course they're not going to
do that and that is the question that is
why remain campaigners people making the
case for us to stay and keep coming back
to this point
what does outlook like I don't say that
there's no one certainty ahead of course
there is in either option but at least
you have more certainty and you know
what you have now whereas you don't know
what you're going to get if we leave
okay thank you Nigel Farage's just
looking at some of the things you've
been seeing recently up I'm already
thinking that you don't really you don't
care anymore if we're part of the single
market well the question was very
interesting this single market Stewart
is affable
services Liz talked about completing the
single market
services it's been going since 1986 and
still we're no nearer to British
insurance companies being able to freely
sell their products in Germany the point
that you're betting the point about
access to a single market is we keep
well but the point is services financial
services it's got us nowhere and we keep
hearing the remain sites they are to
access the single market we have to pay
a membership fee oh no we don't to
access the single market we have to have
the free movement of people oh no we
don't Stuart the osteo question is every
country in the world has access to the
single market the single market is
nothing to do with politicians its
consumers business in the world isn't
done by politicians it's done by
consumers who choose to buy our products
if they like the price and trustor about
the reliability and who I'd rather we
have extensible free trade deal with
what is now the biggest export market
for the eurozone in the world but even
if that went wrong a steward implies in
his question the cost of tariffs even in
the worst case scenario would be less
than our current level of contribution
and while I'm at it I keep hearing
Norway I keep being told by everybody
from the paranoid Norway is it running
well it's very hard it's the Reg in
Norway so everybody keeps saying
wouldn't it be dreadful if we were like
Norway wouldn't it be awful can you
imagine being rich free and able to
catch your own fish Norway doesn't sound
too warm for the maze and
do you know what do you know do you know
what the Norwegians this supremely
sovereign free nation of fish eaters do
you know what do you know what they call
their membership of the European
Economic Area they call it facts
democracy what do you know why I dunno I
mean are they not it's like a committee
set of [ __ ] they're gonna bide by
they don't have to abide by the rules
after abide by the rules of the single
market to have access to it and they
have no say over the rules whatsoever
they are written by other countries
anywhere is the control and sovereignty
now what does the latest opinion poll in
Norway st. I what have no opinion polls
over the last 15 years consistently said
about whether they should join the EU
79% of Norwegians prefer this imperfect
deal with their fax machines and talk to
what we have which is having to apply
113 occasionally you are making the case
not an opinion polls you're making the
case that they have greater control they
have a catastrophic loss of control
which is why the of course and prime
minister said they're not a lot of our
exam fisheries we deal with some
paranormal rice MEAP Emily's Dale hey
Lewis and Marty's on Norway can we get
this right because for the whole of the
remain campaign you Nick the Prime
Minister and others have kept coming out
with this complete untruth that Norway
has to abide by all the rules and has no
say between 2000 and 2015 the Norwegians
who incidentally export 80% of their
overseas goods to European Union
countries Norway abided by 9 percent of
European Union legislation they have the
absolute right of veto over any EU
legislation and frankly if we want to
sell goods to America we have to have to
apply by their rules without having a
say in Congress stop lying about Norway
Norway is doing very very alright indeed
we're gonna know we got a lot more
questions to get through I'm still
trying to work out wife the Norwegians
are so rich they're still using fax
machines but that's a that's a different
issue
I think the me Matthew Piggott please
Matthew Pickett good evening Chuck I'm
afraid you don't recognize me I can't
see you just get on with a question
history shows us that time oil in Europe
means time oil in the UK is it safe to
leave Europe to the Europeans Kate Hoey
so I'm sorry I didn't hear the cat
question can you repeat it again history
shows us that turmoil in Europe leads to
either turmoil in the UK or turmoil we
end up having to get involved in so is
it wise to leave Europe to the Europeans
well we're part of Europe even if we
leave the EU's and that's another myth
that the BSE lot put rind and by the way
can I just say because I really think
it's important on that last question who
didn't call mean I didn't shout light
enough Norway that the reality is no
please don't no I'm sick it's why we've
done that I know that we've got more
questions to get through if you keep
going back to the previous one we'll
never get on well Italy stick to the
question well I cannot for it not just
to explain to everybody with six people
debating here I cannot let everybody
reply to every question my job is to
make sure I'm fair to both sides and
replying not to you as individuals so
I've asked you to answer Matthew biggest
question which have not forgotten
sorry
but well I'm not sure I'm gonna remind
you I would I would say on the turmoil
in Europe and yes
I'm afraid this goes back to a previous
question as well because I didn't get in
on it either and that is that is when we
look at where the most people died in
the in Europe in the last 20 30 years
the EU could not do anything to sort out
the terrible situation in Bosnia and
several niches and we needed the United
States to come in and help so the idea
that somehow the EU keeps us safer and
keeps the Europe safer is a nonsense so
I'm not sure whether that asks answers
the last question tonight as well let me
go to the next question because it's
related to the one we've just had from
Antonia filmer Antonia your question
please tensions with Russia are growing
if things come to Christ this point
would we be safer in or out of the EU if
the Russian bear is rumbling are we
better in or out of the EU Dan Hannon it
makes no difference as long as we're in
NATO and there's a case for being in or
out of NATO but that's the military
alliance whether or not we're in the EU
I think makes no difference although I
did hear jean-claude juncker the other
day saying we need a European army not
in order to use it he said but in order
to scare Vladimir Putin now I mean I
don't claim to be any kind of expert in
the psychology of the Russian autocrat
but I doubt that he stays awake at night
fretting at the prospect of jean-claude
Juncker saying to NATO guys don't worry
we'll take this one from here
so I
I would feel safer retaining the Western
alliance that has served us very well
and I'll just say that I think that our
departure may be a moment for democratic
renewal for the whole of the European
Union they have swatted aside every
other no vote in every other referendum
but a large member country saying this
is it we're not going to have this
remote self-serving clique handing down
its rules to democratic national
parliaments anymore might just lead to
other countries having a better deal to
put in the place of the current EU one
that respects the sovereignty and
restate the question was about Russia
and you mentioned NATO if you think the
future of NATO would be in safe and
Donald Trump's hands no I wouldn't be a
supporter of Donald Trump in any
circumstance so given that he is the
lead Republican contender at the moment
we cannot can we always depend on
America to run NATO pick up the bills
provide the troops in the material we
can't always enter plus when you use a
word like always necessarily because the
future is as all of us have agreed
necessarily unpredictable but we are
surely better off as a sovereign country
making alliances with our friends and
allies on every continent as they come
together bound by common values and
common interests than handing over
control of our foreign policy or our
defence to the institutions in Brussels
that gave us the C AP and the common
fisheries well is candle does our
security and I don't mean in this case
against terrorism I mean against
geopolitical developments like the the
rise of a more aggressive Russia under
mr. Putin does it does the EU helpers or
is it fundamentally NATO that we depend
on for that I think that you does help
us I mean we did manage to agree
sanctions against Russia after their
aggression in the Ukraine and as I said
in my opening comments you know Vladimir
Putin will cheer if we you know vote for
brexit I don't want
Britain or other EU countries being
distracted by protracted renegotiations
of all our deals we have to focus on the
big challenges we've got yes the
migration crisis but also issues like
the rise in Russian aggression NATO is
vital but we don't have to choose
between the two and it is a serious
concern that weakening the EU will play
into Putin's hands and I don't want to
see that happen Nigel Farage is it not a
concern that all of our allies all of
our allies most famously recently our
most important ally the United States
want us to stay but the one country that
probably doesn't is Russia
I think what's a concern is that the
European Union has been very
deliberately and openly provocative
towards Russia the the idea the idea and
Mr Cameron in fact has been in the
vanguard of this very much so and it
ever since
ever since David Cameron became
Conservative Party leader one of his big
ambitions is that the European Union
should extend to include the Ukraine now
we're moving down the track towards that
already we've got a visa access free
deal with Ukraine being negotiated the
Dutch voted against it in a referendum
the other week though I suspect they'll
probably just be ignored and the point
about Putin is leave Ukraine as a buffer
state I don't like the way he operates I
would never want to live in his country
but let's not be openly provocative on
Putin and I worry and I worry and I
worry and I worry that we're part of a
European Union which if we remain within
it
now intends to have a strong foreign
policy and he's hell-bent on creating
its own European army now I said this in
2014 and all clickers over here said
that it was a dangerous fantasy to
suggest they'd ever be a European army
Nick they're building it increasingly
this is a militarized European Union and
I don't like look of it I prefer NATO
where sovereign states cooperate
together hey Clara we do
nice on his willfully competes talking
about the border force that quite
rightly is being put in dice to try and
out try and monitor the because I don't
know I kinda see we've heard that why
we've had something quite extraordinary
this evening we've heard Nigel for us
reinvent saying that we or Brussels or
somebody has provoked Putin yes he
marched into Ukraine and annexed Crimea
Brussels does
well European didn't do that and the
only way the only reason the only reason
why his aggression is continued
aggression in world is now a frozen
conflict in eastern Ukraine the only
reason is showing any restraint
whatsoever is because Russian exporters
the Russian economy is massively
dependent on the economic superpower at
its neighbors which is at its borders
which is the European Union and that
economic superpower has imposed
meaningful sanctions that is a
absolutely crystal clear example of
clout that we would never have never
have on our own in the face of what I
consider to be immoral illegal and
unacceptable aggression and Adi it's
outrageous that he tries to excuse it
what all right Andrew Andrew we won't
move on
Andrew tonight Joe has a say on that let
me get a question out from hips
Taylor pips Taylor Swift to me pips high
if we vote to leave the EU could it lead
to the breakdown of the United Kingdom
well the lead to the breakup I think of
the young famine yeah breakup don't
worry matches my humble job to staying
it make sure you break down say what you
want which I get to you just relax
um Kate Hoey will they not lead to the
breakup of the United Kingdom no if
we're talking about the Scottish
dimension the Scottish Nationalist Party
want to have a referendum at the
slightest opportunity so I don't think
whether we leave or stay will have
anything to do with that I also think
it's important to point out because
there is this kind of myth around that
the whole of the Scottish National Party
the whole of Scotland is somehow
desperate to stay in the EU
think we'll see on during the 20 so just
how wrong that is because the Scottish
groups are just as split as many of you
know the rest of the United Kingdom I
really genuinely don't think it will
make make a difference and I also think
the idea that somehow they would vote it
to leave and then want to have to rejoin
if they were independent and to take the
euro which they'd have to do under the
EU rules so I don't think that's true
and as far as Ireland Northern Ireland
is concerned you know I'm from Northern
Ireland and very very strongly people in
Northern Ireland still despite
everything that's happened by a huge
majority want to stay part of the United
Kingdom they want to trade with the with
the Republic of Ireland they want to be
friends it won't make the slightest bit
of difference and it's another bit of a
sort of kind of lettering something else
to scare people don't be fooled to come
on okay so the Union say even if we vote
to leave the European Union I think if
we vote to leave the European Union I
think Scottish independence will very
much be on the cosgood but can I just
ask cake is up she said something very
interesting though about Scott oh is it
SIA can you you it is it safe are you
answering a question is it sick I did I
just said that I think I think that the
the UK could split up if we leave the
European Union but the question I was
just going on so you don't think it's
safe yeah he thinks it'll spring break
up yes I also what's the question well
my question was Kate said something
quite interesting if I heard her
correctly which is that actually there
is a mix of views and amongst Scottish
MPs and others there are different views
on the European Union and whether we
should stay in or we should come out
okay can you name a SNP MP who wants us
to leave the European Union well I I
have been told Jim siller's is leading a
very she's not answer no he's not in
there he's not an MP in Parliament would
would he stop worrying
yes lemke so don't name someone who's
not an MP well Jim sinners is
an auntie an anti-eu group in the
Scottish Nationalist Party this
obsession with MPs thank goodness is
only whatever 658 of us with a boat
there are millions of people with a vote
and the idea that just because MPs in a
party
the point is knighted that somehow that
yes MP this disappear been finished with
the range it'll will be my people out
there actually deciding that the
politicians aren't always right that's
true I wouldn't disagree with that
just hold the record Kate Hoey did I
understand you to say that you think
that uh Scotland is going to vote to
leave no no what I said was it the way
the media blame the media with the way
the political parties the little elite
of all the established parties that are
all saying we've got to remain they're
implying that somehow Scotland is so
different from the rest of the United
Kingdom in terms of its you don't think
it ought to leave
I would hope that I'd hope that the
majority know we're going to leave but I
don't think the difference in majority
of whatever it is will be that different
in Scotland from England or Northern
Ireland or well it's for the record
we'll see on the night next question
from Robert wheel Robert um it's David
chopper I'm I'm asking a question on
behalf of Robert wheel well there better
be the same one yeah hey could you get
here cuz of the rail stock I understand
thank you and the question is if we vote
to remain how will we control Eirik
immigration from the EU if we vote to
remain how will we control immigration
from the EU Liz Kendall well I for one
I'm actually pleased with the part of
the renegotiation the Prime Minister has
achieved by saying people who come to
work in this country who come to this
country should work and contribute
before they're able to claim benefits
that's something I strongly argue for
during the labor leadership campaign but
I believe that you know immigration in
this country has brought massive
challenges without a doubt and I would
be the first to say that I've seen it in
my own constituency but I also
personally
think we need to stand up for the
contribution that migrants make in this
country setting up businesses working
for our NHS the fact that they put far
more into the system than claim out you
know I want clear rules excuse me he
didn't ask if immigration was good or
bad which is the question you're
answering what I asked was if we stay in
the EU
how will we control immigration what's
the answer well I was saying the rules
that I believe need to apply which is if
you come here you should come to work
and not claim benefits you should abide
by the rules and values of this country
but that we also need to speak up for
the positive benefits that immigration
has brought to this country that may not
be a popular cause amongst many but I've
seen it in my own constituency in
businesses and the NHS and we should
make that case you say are you saying
that people should only be able to come
here if they've got a job that they
couldn't just come from the EU as job
seekers well my understanding is that
you know since 1995 at least
three-quarters of people who come here
from the EU have you know up work which
is often been a higher proportion than
British boy do they need to have a job
do they need to have a job if you shut
up I'll ask the question
no because that are you saying that you
should have to have a job now I'm not
you know it's part of you know free
movement labor you can live work study
in other countries and we also have to
how would you control who comes here
from the EU can you do it uh I do
believe that we need to have make sure
that we have stronger border controls
that's something that we have campaigned
on for a long time oh no no no I believe
that we need strong border controls and
those clear rules and I think that it's
you know what the Prime Minister has
negotiated would help but I also want to
make the positive case for the benefits
that immigration brings is it nigel
Faraj desirable that we should clamp
major controls on immigration from the
rest of the EU because given that our
economies been performing pretty well
and much of Europe hasn't we have
managed to attract some of the best and
the brightest of Europe to come and work
in our country why would you want to
stop that because when you have an open
door what do you have an open door you
will attract some of the best and the
brightest but you will also attract a
number of people that you'd rather
hadn't come in the first place we're not
even able to stop foreign criminals from
Europe coming into our country and we
should be able to do so David the
question you know if we vote to remain
what will we be able to do couldn't
control immigration the answer is we
won't be able to control immigration if
we stay in the European Union and these
lies I mean Cameron spent ten million
quid of your money putting a leaflet
through your door telling you that if
you vote to remain we will retain border
controls all we do is ask people to
flash a passport
we are completely effectively borderless
half a billion people can freely come
here and let me predict that with the EU
enlarging including Turkey and given
that the eurozone is headed back into
serious crisis and Greece will need to
be barreled out again at some point in
the course of this year the numbers of
people fleeing poverty in Europe can
only increase and we need to be tough
about
we need to make sure that we take Andrew
the brightest and the best but we've got
to do so in limited numbers this is the
number one issue in British politics
every single poll says immigration
security jobs are at the top of people's
agenda in Britain and the only way of
dealing with this is to vote to leave
the European Union and take back control
of our borders and I am just clarify one
point I understand that if we leave the
EU we'd have more control over who comes
to work here from the EU I take that
point but would we have any more control
over you citizens who are coming to
visit us I mean do you envisage that to
control that you would introduce visas
for EU sirs so I don't we should need to
do that at all I don't see any need for
us to have to have visas but I do see
the absolute need for people if they
want to get jobs to register so we know
who they are how long they're going to
be here for and that we don't even
consider paying benefits or entitlements
to anybody until they've legally been in
the country worked for five years paid
taxes into the system and obeyed the law
Hickman's plain common sense frankly
Clegg and that's what the population
wants I think David the the blunt sort
of truth is and I while so I strongly
disagree with what Theresa May said was
it yesterday about coming out of the
human rights convention I agreed with
the way she characterized this she
basically said look could fully
controlling immigration if that's your
objective is actually pretty difficult
whether you're inside the European Union
or not as I said earlier if you've got
good examples of major economies
Australia Canada you know the United
States which per head of population have
much higher and before Nigel says
because they're big countries small
countries like Liechtenstein Switzerland
Norway have much higher immigration the
capita than we do even though they're
not part of the European Union in fact
in some respects it might be more
difficult the French could not have been
clearer they said if we pull out of the
European Union the border controls we
presently have on French soil
we'd be moved to to Kent so I think I
think I think to try and have a kind of
a sort of accurate debate on this we
have to kind of admit there is no
scenario in
out of your opinion where you can
completely seal your border so
hermetically seal your borders and nor
is there in other parts of the world
either in the modern world in which we
do the question it's just to bring you
back to the question it was if we've got
to remain how will we control
immigration from the EU I mean isn't the
honest answer is that we can't and we
don't the honest answer is people just
like many many Brits many many Brits
retire live study work abroad in the
European Union people who exercise the
right to work in this country can come
and seek to do so there are plenty of
checks and controls which we can reject
people as we have against thousands of
people if we think they will do our
country harm but yes you're absolutely
right that the principle that we can all
as many many Brits do it is a two-way
street seek to work in other parts of
the European remains my point simply was
don't believe the kind of suggestion
because there's just no evidence in any
other country not least in some of the
countries Norway etc which are lauded as
a great example there is no example of a
country which has somehow managed to
sort of built well Donald Trump wants to
build a wall against the Mexicans that's
a good example they're having a very
similar debate
I don't think his wall is going to work
if you ever build in the same way that I
don't think pulling the Hungarians have
already make the immigration issue about
the Hungarians have already built a wall
there in the EU the Austrians have
closed the Bremner pass and Montenegro
which is planning to become a member the
EU has built a massive fence and they're
not going to work they're not going to
work in the long run in the long run in
my view the only and by the way this is
why it's a good thing that we remained
out of the Schengen a range of the
Schengen arrangement as you know is this
amenity to move around the Schengen
countries within the European without
showing your passport the reason why
it's good we're out of that is because
Schengen the fundamental floor of
Schengen was that they removed internal
borders without imposing external border
checks which is what they're now doing
through this new border force that's
what they need to sort out all these
fences going up across Europe are
absolutely not the way forward I'm going
to find a question from grant effort if
we can get the mic tuned before I do
down hand I said I know why we are not
falling for these ghost stories from the
remain campaign is because in the middle
of all the fear and doubt
you suddenly get some utterly rizal
implausible claims such as we just had
that the Calais jungle will move to Kent
right now the idea that we would have
migrant camps in Kent any more than we
have them at Gatwick or Heathrow or any
other point of entry is utterly absurd
all three speakers actually answer that
question in this in very different ways
but they all gave the same answer if we
stay in the EU we cannot control net
inward migration into this country the
key word there is control I think night
and I slightly differ in our view about
immigration I'm quite in favor of having
a measure of legal primary immigration
into this country and I'm in favor of
having a refugee element as well
probably a bit more than night realism
but if I'm going to make that argument
people need to know in exchange that we
are in charge roughly of who comes in
and we are in charge roughly of what
numbers and as long as we're in the EU
we have no such sense and apart from the
craziness of taking unqualified EU
migrants over qualified migrants from
elsewhere I think there is a basic
immorality of basic unfairness with the
way that we are treating old friends and
allies who stood by us in the two wars
when we were most in need
I have constituents from Commonwealth
backgrounds and all of the MPs who will
have the same story people who now may
have may have family support for us in
one or other of the war who can't now
bring auntie over for a wedding I mean
not not to settle here right just a
visit because we've so cracked down on
the non EU part of our migration policy
in order to free up unlimited space for
Google may have zero connection there
are still more migrants coming to this
country from non EU countries we have
per country a lot less he said he
couldn't get in but yeah and and an
auntie can come Andrew if you were to
get any wounded constituency surgeries
and I think chukar and Nichol be honest
enough to tell you that they've had the
same thing almost everyone is having and
Liz I'm sorry almost everyone is having
this problem I have a constituent now
who has been married to a woman for 12
years in st. Lucia right this is not
some fish am marriage he cannot now come
into this country because a practical
limiter how many people you can bring in
and we've had to open our boats you
we still bring more in from the non EU
them from the EU yes the thing I want us
to be able to decide who comes in on the
basis of merit oh I understand all that
connections country and you go to
language final word for you on this well
I'll tell you what my constituents say
about this and the interesting thing
about the immigration debate actually is
that many of those who raised concerns
with me around immigration the most are
my black and Asian constituents and all
they in the end tell me they want they
want people to pay into the system
before they take out they want proper
enforcement of our labor market
regulations they want people to be
helped to learn English if they come
here and to integrate but the reason in
the end they don't go for this kind of
dog-whistle stuff on immigration is
because in the end all the things that
people are saying about Eastern
Europeans now are very very similar to
what people were saying about my father
when he came here in the mid 1960s and
Asian people and they don't want any
truck with that okay thank you for that
in one final very quick question before
we go to the the book we're over running
a little bit but I think you'll
understand why given the quality of the
debate grant effort thank you thank you
for leaving the the best to last and
I'll be the judge of that on June 23rd
can we also vote to leave the Eurovision
Song Contest yes or no will do Nigel
Faraj I think the whole thing has been
rigged against us right from the start
it's a conspiracy
sooner out the back Kate Hoey yes
absolutely I would like to get out of it
as well I think it's not worth watching
anymore
Dan hanim let's have another referendum
I'm always and everywhere in favor of
this que no no I love it definitely not
I'd I love that you revision come on
it's great why is this real allowed to
be in the Eurovision song don't know and
I don't care oh let's not go there
new Clegg I've missed Terry Wogan I get
a brilliant oh and we're safer and
stronger and better in the Eurovision
Song Contest ha ha Chuck I'm owner ha ha
ha Chuck is music this harmless isn't it
at the end of the day and sometimes this
is a very serious debate what's the harm
in having a laugh and the Eurovision is
a laugh isn't it very well now we come
to the moment of the debate you have the
vote you will have all should have three
different things you can only hold them
up it's remain leave our undecided let
me ask first of all can we put up the
house lights a little bit so I can see
I'm going to ask Dan and Liz to help me
adjudicate on on this all right and we
can see you up there too yep can I ask
first of all who is still undecided oh
well well a good view is the answer who
wants to vote to leave
very skeptical and who wants to vote to
remain well leaves have it the leaves
have it
ladies and gentlemen thank you if you
were a uric rat you'd make them vote
again until they got the right results
well we may have another debate and they
can vote again dan let me first of all
thank you all for coming tonight and
participating being such a wonderful
audience everywhere a great debater
that's still a lot undecided so there's
all to play for on both sides
thanks to Rathbones for sponsoring
tonight on the way out you'll see all
sorts of little spectator things you can
buy maybe even get free one of them are
highly recommend is this little pocket
you stick on back on the back of your
phone and you can stick your credit
cards in it it's perfect and you Bram
the spectator to and it means you can
lose your phone and your credit cards at
the same time before you go ladies and
gentlemen a huge round of applause for
our wonderful debaters
and
No
thank you and good night in trouble
safely good night
you